The carpal tunnel is a narrow passage in the
wrist.
It is formed by wrist bones on the bottom
and sides and a tough band of connective tissue,
called the transverse carpal ligament, on
top.
Muscle tendons and the median nerve pass through
the carpal tunnel.
The median nerve controls muscles in the palm
and base of the thumb, allowing them to move.
It also provides feeling to the thumb and
nearby two and a half fingers.
Carpal tunnel syndrome is a condition where
tissue swelling causes pressure to build up
within the carpal tunnel.
This puts pressure on the median nerve.
Over time median nerve pressures results in
symptoms in the areas of hand it supplies.
Common symptoms in these areas are pain, numbness,
tingling, and weakness.
Risk factors for carpal tunnel syndrome include
a smaller carpal tunnel from being female
or from genes passed down from parents, wrist
injuries, other medical conditions that cause
inflammation, fluid buildup, or nerve damage
such as diabetes, pregnancy, rheumatoid arthritis,
obesity, and hypothyroidism, and repetitive
hand or wrist motions.
A common treatment for mild to moderate carpal
tunnel syndrome is keeping the wrist in a
neutral position by wearing a brace or splint.
In addition, non-steroidal anti-inflammatory
drugs, or NSAIDs, may help relieve pain.
A doctor may recommend a corticosteroid injection
to reduce inflammation and swelling.
For moderate to severe symptoms, a doctor
may recommend a surgical procedure called
carpal tunnel release.
This procedure may be done as an open procedure
through an incision between the palm and wrist,
or it may be done as an endoscopic procedure
through a small keyhole incision.
The surgeon will perform this procedure with
an endoscope, which is a device containing
a tiny camera and surgical instruments.
In both procedures the transverse carpal ligament
will be cut to relieve pressure on the median
nerve.
At the end of either procedure the incision
will be closed with sutures.